all right its hatred mail I have yet
another new hatred mail tag line or new
introduction to present to you sort of
in the interest of keeping hatred mail
timely take a listen to this hey let's
face it the only logical response to
guns is more freakin guns Patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay there is something very
different about this week's hatred mail
and I'm not going to give away what it
is I'm going to play the hatred mail for
you and see if you can figure out what
just seems a little bit different about
this week's a tree mail
David is more of a Hispanic Ike his
parents probably killed the innocent
babies of several Roman Catholic
Gentiles in Argentina and were
subsequently deported to the land of the
free where it's okay to feast in the
progeny of Gentiles so long as you have
enough money and influence what do you
think what do you think was different
about that hatred mail versus many many
others it's incredibly well written yeah
the content is completely depraved and
disgusting xenophobic anti-semitic
anti-hispanic but it's quite well
constructed as far as the English
language goes yeah I'm used to deranged
Patriot mail yes but not eloquent one
absolutely this may be the best ever
written hate the best written hatred
mail that we have ever had and the good
news is that whether hatred mail is well
written or poorly written you can give a
middle finger salute to the hey tree
'it's by using the coupon code hey tree
at forty to get a forty percent discount
off of any membership whatever
membership you like at david pakman.com
slash membership hey tree at forty as a
coupon code will save you forty percent